welcome to American radium you're paid
one cent per diet your work suffers miss
Cavallo
viii looks like a fat toddler this
month's top painter Josephine Cavallo
will you help me practice lying feeling
spaces
I'm studying I have to be ready to be
discovered and go to Hollywood I want to
find it to like touch when I'm an
archeologist
[Music]
Joe will be ready in five minutes Joe
don't come in please Joe I don't know
what's wrong with her I'm dizzy my
joints ache I lost a tooth and two
others are loose do you know what's
wrong with me
absolutely nothing you're healthy as a
horse where do you work
American radio with dial painters we
believe that exposure to radium can
cause devastating tissue damage
good for you everyone knows that what
does this mean for us you take American
radium down there's a doctor that can
test if your bones are radioactive I see
you sound crazy
I'm not losing my job over this I'm
scared I'm not going back in there I'm
looking for Bessie and Josephine Apollo
they did a study years ago they own it
own research that's absurd it's like
owning gravity American radium is
denying the harmful effects of radium
all they have to do is run out the clock
they could drag this out for years you
don't have yours
you'll never win doing it no matter what
you swear to tell the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth did you
everyone put down your brushes radium is
poison
Bessie you're trespassing I won't
abandon you they're trying to silence
you they must be stopped
I am going to make American radium pay
for what they've done
[Music]
I can only
[Music]